alors j'ai reçu une vidéo d'un
téléspectateur ne touche pas à mon poste
regardez cette vidéo ça lui là bas je
t'envoie ce petit message pour que tu
puisse nous aider
moi ma soeur et mon beau-frère c'est un
peu la galère en ce moment à kim n'a pas
de permis et n'a pas trop les moyens de
les passer on habite en campagne donc
quand ils trouvent une mission pour
aller bosser
bah c'est la galère pour ma soeur
d'autant plus qu'ils ont une petite
fille d'un an et il faut que tu fasses
quelque chose s'il te plaît baba merci
[Applaudissements]
et ce soir hakim et olivia sa femme son
docu
[Musique]
sa macro kg lydia commencé ma chérie
fabien alors acquis mais olivia olivia
travail dans un fait quoi dans la vie
est faite pour lui moche et soignante
les fans ont très bien et toi baqim tu
fais moi je ferai en ce moment tu fais
rien mais tu as besoin du permis
voilà c'est ça thorgal r on en campagne
et où c'est un peu je les invite en
campagne voilà je sais et tu fait de
l'intérim - donc un peu en place
tu as besoin de seulement d'avoir le
permis pour travailler voilà c'est ça
mon chéri et leclerc me c'est vrai que
c'est une tannée pour l'avoir c'est ça
coûte de l'eau des nacelles permis donc
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de te faire
gagner tout permis on va essayer alors
je vais bien par les autorités kelly
avait novelli qui est devenue maintenant
à quoi animatrice de l'émission volée
alors
le sort de votre permis se trouve dans
les mains et dans la bouche de certains
à yakro t il les a message est sans
avenir
alors mettez vous la mettez vous la
regardez il ya là un coffre fort non il
ya un coffre-fort avec un code les trois
chroniqueurs qui les enfants vont devoir
faire gagner et faire gagner le permis
ac pour faire gagner
ah oui le permis c'est très simple il va
avoir deux minutes deux minutes pour
trouver le code du coffre fort on va
aller makeli alors qu'on soit devoir se
trouvent une voie du code on va démarrer
le code dans le mauvais sens c'est à
dire on va démarrer par isabelle pour
laisser kénié benjamin qui sont les plus
stressés sarapp aux hammers des
paillages parce que je sais que bachar
matin accra pour le joueur je veux pas
et je ne crois pas que les crapauds tu
parles je rajoute croire en plus je
découvre des mesures et bien sûr eux
c'est peut-être un crapaud isabelle
c'est très simple bon vous isabelle vous
allez devoir rattraper le carton qui est
dans un plastique mec la bouche est
plutôt tranquille pour vous qu'elle vous
foutez de moi je la sens ici le coiffeur
ce matin c'est fermé deux aaa alors mais
on fabrique la première est ce que vous
croyez ça passe pas en dessous mais y'a
des pareils à des coiffeurs ici
attention isabelle je vais mettre le
chrono je voudrais arrêter à tout moment
le chrono attention c'est parti vous
avez deux minutes pour que j'attrape
avec les toits avec les dents attention
c'est parti
vous allez ça sera la fin du tout
[Musique]
c'est avec la bouche est kama la pala
non non non non non non des centaines
[Musique]
alors c'est la panique à thouarcé 88
hashtag machin-là 4,4 et dietz 4 et dias
que le dies vous l'avez déjà donc c'est
le 4g se terminera par quatre attention
on va faire maintenant le début du code
vous avez arrêté le chrono il reste
quand même temps on va faire le début du
code avec vous kelly kelly vdev dit on
terminera avec benjamin castaldi qui est
le plus précis kelly vous allez devoir
passer votre main là dedans c'est là la
même circonférence que je dois trouver
le même papier la soul à peu près oui
esthétique ah oui bon franchement
c'était comme ça pas ouf
bah allez y mettez votre notebook est
allé chercher à la la la la la
j'y vais ou pas doucement les animaux
la presse
[Musique]
je le fais et ça sera la donne à fond je
le ferai à bazas marcel aymard flanqué
d'un fonds cyril je sais je sais je suis
moi est situé le bois merci et
maintenant casta diva vous restez 53
secondes
aïe aïe aïe aïe castaldi 53 secondes
pour faire gagner le permet je peux pas
mettre la main là dedans castaldi qu'est
ce que vous aimeriez ne pas voir du tout
d'ailleurs je me plais grapo je peux pas
je voulais dire on est bien installé une
fois de plus vous avez de la chance dans
votre vie puisque regarder on voit rien
bon c'est un tas crapaud voulez vous
c'est une énorme bobard
jama monstre qu'on ne peut pas non merci
à mon collègue à moteur ont des causes
[Applaudissements]
en sont permis
pour le breton
je vais pas bien il reste 19 objets je
vous nous fait pas peur personne n'offre
rien non
théorie mais non il est énorme
[Musique]
oui un peu mais à l'époque il reste 19
je vois pas mes gamins dans le il est là
le pauvre le brave il ne lui fait pas de
mal aux cheveux les jardins et nous le
truc mais l'arrière mettez vous bien je
vais vous mettez vous donc mais pourquoi
vous voulez nos métiers c'est une
torture nous devons d'avoir six secondes
calme-toi lui fallait regarder c'est
très simple vous faites comme ceux ci et
vous prenez le bail d'accord les
secondes c'est trop tard
[Applaudissements]
les sans-papiers et passera les rênes
avec avec moi avec mais on n'est pas
content vous jamais de paraître regardez
arrête de bouger tout ça mais pas du
tout moi je tombe
soyez gentil avec lui et senna chez sa
compagne allez allez
mais ya pas mal at on pas né avec kenny
n'a été vus main dans la main tous les
doigts les i
mais sinon je ne sais pas et bouger les
dédales papiers ménagers baseya on y va
je devais me dis moi les allées vengeant
m'imaginais pas fait attention
allez allez sur son ménage où je le peux
pas abordé qu'en soit l'issue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
choux et les choux le pouce il ne bouge
pas votre papier baryté tu le vois le
papier marges selon allez c'est bon tu
ferais pas c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est une phobie 3,04
il ya le permis de conduire que tu
gagnes voilà mon chéri et il paraît
qu'un autre cadeau c'est quoi notre
cadeau ayant un pack high tech
[Applaudissements]
donc vous avez permis vous avez le pack
high tech
je sais qu'en ce moment c'est très très
dur pour vous franchement je sais que
vous galérez et j'ai kiffé la vidéo ton
pote maxime
donc j'ai envie que tu décompresse avant
de passer son permis
vous allez partir en séjour au soleil
tout l'été
[Applaudissements]
merci
andres izarra